[Music]
foreign
ER has given us a very important mission
for tonight Target is across the street
we must use stealth and cut it to
infiltrate the human world and retrieve
Gogurt
[Music]
it was very specific about the party
size he underlined it twice all right
Donnie you're on toiletries RAF you're
stocking up the pantry and Mikey you're
on juncus and remember don't let any
human see you because why humans are the
demons come of the earth
and hey I know that's objectively
prejudiced but that's what Dad taught us
uh I think humans seem kind of cool to
be honest Beyonce that guy's the goat
I'd love to have a champagne brunch with
Tom Brady I fear he seems like a fun
Hank and I've always wanted to go to
flavor Town look we all think humans are
cool but we got a job to do let's go
you have bronchitis
stop boys where have you been I've been
freaking out sorry guys
I'm scared of cats so yeah yeah
you said you were go shopping then come
right back
where were you oh uh look we're really
sorry Spooner some of the guys want to
see a movie and I try to talk them out
of it
to move it with the humans yeah you
ratted us out hey don't use that word
that way that was sorry Dad
yo come on y'all let's get the goods
got some little tortoises huh look at
look at y'all adorable man bad burning
got some turtles on the paper no what we
don't we're burning we're here to find
you I can't leave there
if they're us this is wow I mean this is
crazy like let me guess 15 years ago
right some sludge was dumped in the
sewer and y'all came from that well we
prefer the term ooze but yeah it's like
more like it's just it's a tongue better
yeah
it's nice
I like that I like ooze so look look
that same ooze made me okay my dad
Baxter Stockman he's the one who dumped
the Ooze down the drain baby so
technically we cousins
I've always wanted a cousin well look at
you now you got a bunch
one day 15 years ago everything changed
it was covered in this woo someone dumb
in the source whatever this rules is
worse it transformed us
it was weird but we became a family
um
[Music]
you know what's perfect about today
everything yep
all right how's the neighborhood watch
going Lucy what's happening nothing just
pink lots and lots of pink I don't hate
the pink kind of dreamy do these people
work how can they afford all this all
right boys we're off to work don't get
too much sun Good Luck running the world
have fun in outer space
wow these people haven't figured out
yeah they can have their mansions and
Astronaut jobs because we'll always have
pizza hey enough sitting around let's
Gear Up
[Music]
did you film that sorry am I supposed to
film all the stuff you do because a lot
of is dumb
[Music]
that one seems cool bruh Broski bro bro
abracadabra
[Music]
the turtles
Mondo quit hugging everybody
no exclusively movie theaters August 2nd
get your tickets now
I think the animation and the flavor of
the movie is so original and fresh
what we wanted to do was create an
incredibly fun and engaging version of
the Ninja Turtles we had this idea that
they had to feel like real teenagers
Turtle Boy actually I would say teams
they need to look like teenagers they
need to sound like teenagers it's like
what if it's animated by teenagers
the Doodles that you do and the size of
your notebook were taken extrapolated
and made into the look of a whole movie
weird shapes and praising perspective
you would reach this point where you're
like a little bit more rescue and
misshapen great it's perfect
he kept using this term teenage energy
over and over again
let's go let's go
visually that these animated movies are
taking the more excited people seem to
be by them
[Music]
as long as I can remember I was an Ninja
Turtles fan
bring to life these characters for a new
generation and the cast is really funny
lady noon is Raphael I dream about
fighting every night we got Mike Abby is
Donatello you're fine chill Nicholas
Cantu is Leonardo we're really sorry
Spooner some of the guys wanted to get
pizza and I tried to talk him out of it
Shimon Brown Jr is Michelangelo why do
we pick a fruit shaped exactly like my
head would record the kids at once the
personalities of the characters came
from the chemistry they had with each
other
don't use that word that way I mean it's
20 20. sorry Dad
Jackie Chan the Splinter he's incredible
anytime you need more call me and Iowa
Demery plays April O'Neil this is insane
Turtle Mutant karate I'm excited to lean
into the mutant element of it we had the
designs and then wrote the personalities
of the characters
in the Monopoly sat my dog ice cube is
Superfly it's also little tortoises huh
me and John Cena are Bebop and
Rocksteady what you looking at bro what
you looking at Mondo Gekko is played by
Paul Rudd people's they got to give post
Malone is Ray fillet
Rose Byrne plays Leatherhead
Giancarlo Esposito plays Baxter Stockman
Natasha Demetrio plays Wing nuts animal
burst like Genghis Frog by a Rudolph
Cynthia utram Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles is a comedic action movie with
heart do you think there are people who
will accept us
no no absolutely not um genuinely no
boys where have you been
we're just running errands that's it
really sorry Splinter some of the guys
wanted to get pizza and I tried to talk
him out of it you ratted us out don't
use that word that way I mean
hey guys if we weren't monsters that
were shunned by society and we could do
what we wanted
what would you guys do go to high school
maybe get a girlfriend can you imagine
that not likely
[Music]
I want to know everything about you our
dad is definitely not a giant rat that
makes me feel like he's a rat
police are baffled by the recent crime
wave led by a Superfly nobody's ever
seen his face why because he kills
everyone who does
no not cool a bit cool we pick out super
fun and then everyone will think we're
cool
he's making a deal tonight under the
Brooklyn Bridge
that's a little tortoises huh I can't
believe there are other mutants you want
to roll with us
humans are never gonna like us
so we gonna let the mutants rule the
Earth
people's they got to go okay um sort of
a twist
can't stop him we gotta try
six in the morning police at my door
my son Michelangelo you have hearts
Donatello you have wisdom Rafael you
have bravery and Leonardo honored
enough talk I dream about fighting every
night you've got a rage
[Music]
foreign